well Florida Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis fresh off of his big win to
re-election in the 2022 midterms has
announced an investigation into
covid vaccines I know I know Ron
DeSantis seems to be going fully
anti-vax we're going to talk about why
he also went on Fox News to attack covet
vaccines but first and foremost holding
a press event yesterday wherein he
announced in conjunction with the
Supreme Court of Florida they will
empanele a grand jury
sounds pretty serious huh to investigate
vaccine wrongdoing in Florida I I know
guys I know it's Bonkers what's going on
let's take a listen to what DeSantis had
to say because in Florida you know it is
against the law to mislead and to
misrepresent particularly when you're
talking about the efficacy of a drug we
see just the other uh just recently
Florida got 3.2 billion through legal
action against those responsible for the
opioid crisis and so it's not like this
is something that's unprecedented so
today I'm announcing a petition with the
Supreme Court of Florida to impanel a
Statewide grand jury to investigate any
and all wrongdoing in Florida with
respect to covid-19 vaccines and we how
powerful how principled
anticipate that we will get the approval
for that uh that will be something that
will be impaneled most likely in the
Tampa Bay Area uh and that will come
with legal processes that will be able
uh to get more information and to bring
legal accountability for those who
committed misconduct yeah now listen
there's two sides to this one side is
it seems as though Florida may have
committed the misconduct in their
opposition and attempt to tear down the
vaccines which I will get to in a moment
but the investigation really should be
of those people now you might remember
Florida involved in all sorts of hijinks
with the vaccine there was the woman who
was putting together that panel to
provide covet information
uh about hospitalizations deaths etc etc
she was fired that was an insane
incident which should be investigated
they have this uh State Surgeon General
or head of Department of Public Health
Dr latapo or ladapo who regularly puts
out covet and covet vaccine
disinformation as a mouthpiece for the
state that should be investigated but
that's not what they want to investigate
this is a point in the pandemic
where cases are again going up
the hospitalizations are
disproportionately the elderly
the deaths are disproportionately the
elderly we are in flu season the numbers
are not good for a group that is over
represented in Florida Florida on
average having a significantly older
population than many other states
DeSantis should be saying hey get your
bivalent boosters because we need the
protection right now but instead he
announces an investigation into vaccine
wrongdoing the wrongdoing is the
anti-vaxx people the pharmacists who
deliberately spoiled vaccines and the
fact that the pharmacists who didn't
really vaccinate people pretended to but
didn't actually vaccinate people the
chiropractor who offered bogus medical
exemptions uh to be unvaccinated to
remain unvaccinated fraudulently and
just to anybody who wanted such an
exemption the people who spread the
disinformation online some of whom work
for this State of Florida that's the
wrong doing we all know exists but
that's not what Ron DeSantis wants to
investigate he after this event
went on Fox News
and that's a whole other aspect to this
which I want to talk about and then we
will sort of uh speculate on why now and
why this and we'll get to that in a
moment before you go if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more please make
sure to subscribe to my YouTube channel
you can click the Subscribe button below
or above or wherever it is on your
screen and if you want to support my
work even more strongly the best way is
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
And subscribe to the podcast for the
David packman show there you can check
out interviews longer clips and much
more it's on all the big podcasting
platforms just search for the David
packman show and all the links are also
Down Below in the video description